it was announced that creed singer scott
stapp
will play frank sinatra in an upcoming
movie
but the good news is sammy davis jr will
be played by scarlett johansson
yeah colin jost was tricked into making
a joke about wife scarlett johansson
on saturday night live i'm kidding i'm
kidding
she's great she's great during snl's
final episode of 2020
colin and his weekend update co-host
michael che
took part in colin's least favorite
year-end tradition
blindly reading jokes they wrote for one
another on
air we're making each other read jokes
live on
air that the other person has never seen
before yeah
fun harmless inoffensive jokes right jay
yeah man won't you go first though
which is how we got this moment it was
announced that
creed singer scott staff will play frank
sinatra in an upcoming movie
but the good news is sammy davis jr will
be played by scarlett johansson
the shockingly biting jab seemingly
references scarlet's past
controversies involving accusations of
whitewashing in her movies
most notably her leading role in the
ghost in the shell
this is major colin did force michael to
say
this joke though it was revealed that
the sequel to the movie hocus pocus
is in the works for disney plus which by
judging
which judging by this picture is a movie
about every white woman i've ever slept
with
[Applause]
cool so maybe they're even but
back to colin and scarjo yeah wedding
planning that's
a thing you're supposed to do it doesn't
just happen
the two tied the knot in october in a
small ceremony collaborating with meals
on wheels to announce their nuptials on
instagram
and the caption just married the pair
got engaged in 2019
after two years of dating i don't know
what this world's going to be after
tuesday
and michael che had this to say on snl
the next day
which was also the final episode before
election day
i may never see you again colin i mean
we might both get drafted in the race
war
it's not fair you just married scarlett
johansson and i just bought an electric
bike
we're both doing equally great
it's become a bit on the show to make
colin uncomfortable with jokes about his
high-profile relationship
in february collins snl castmate chloe
feynman even did an
impression of scarlett right in front of
him and his reaction was
priceless marriage story taught me a lot
about
teacup acting it's like when scarjo was
like
so i saw charlie in this play
and he was this big bear do you feel
like you're at home
calling yeah
[Applause]
thank you it's really good thank you